Let's continue our discussion of the Alyeska case and now we're going to focus
on the question of whether extrinsic evidence can be admitted to supplement a
written contract.
The Alyeska court adopted a three step test to make this determination.
The first step is the partial integration test.
Namely,
was the written agreement partially integrated with respect to the extrinsic
evidence at issue?
In other words,
was the writing a final expression of some of the terms of the contract?
If not,
the parole evidence rule does not apply and even inconsistent or contradictory.
Extrinsic evidence can be admitted.
In this case,
the court found that the December 11th writing was partially integrated,
meaning that the writing was a final expression of some,
uh,
have at least some of the terms.
The court doesn't say much about the standard for what determines whether
writing was partially integrated,
and there have been academic debates about whether extrinsic evidence should be
admitted,
determine whether the writing was a final expression of some,
some,
or all of the,
of the,
of its terms with most courts.
Now considering extrinsic evidence in determining whether parties intended the
written contract to be a partial or complete integration.
The trial court's finding of partial integration is reviewed under the clearly
erroneous standard as a question of fact.
The second test is the consistency test.
If a written agreement was partially integrated,
is the extrinsic evidence in consistent with the integrated portion?
If yes,
the extrinsic evidence cannot be admitted to supplement.
In this case,
the court found that the parole evidence was inconsistent with the written
agreement in making this consideration.
The court rejected.
In making this determination,
the court rejected the hunt food standard.
The hunt food case held that to be inconsistent.
The extrinsic evidence must be offered for a term that contradicts and express
term of the writing.
This definition of consistency is too broad.
Hunt food would destroy much of the parol evidence rule by finding that a very
broad class of extrinsic evidence was consistent and thus could be admitted
unless the writing was an exclusive integration.
For example,
if Laurel agreed to paint Hardy's house in in a written contract for $500,
the hunt food standard would allow hardy to argue that Laura also promised to
sell his car is part of the contract because selling a car wouldn't contradict
an expressed term of the written contract.
On the other hand,
it's possible to interpret consistent very narrowly the phrase additional
consistent terms sounds like an oxymoron.
The this other extreme interpretation is,
uh,
would say that all additional terms are inconsistent because any additional term
is inconsistent with the quid pro quo balance of promises that the parties
agreed to in the initial writing.
The court correctly feels that the hunt food standard is too broad,
but also wants to avoid the other extreme and define all additional terms to be
inconsistent.
The court compromises between these extreme standards by assessing,
assessing consistency,
uh,
under the Snyder definition of inconsistency as quote the absence of reasonable
harmony unquote in the written and extrinsic terms.
Does this reasonable harmony standard help us at all?
Well,
not really.
Notice how the court uses overstatement to shore up a questionable conclusion.
Under this definition of inconsistency,
it is clear that the proffered parole evidence is inconsistent.
As you can probably tell though,
whether there is reasonable harmony or not is far from clear.
Is the inconsistency inquiry different from the May not be contradicted?
Inquiry of section two Dash Two oh two answer is no and inconsistent piece of
evidence is the same as a piece of evidence that contradicts the reasonable
agreement.
The opinion suggests there's really no difference between an inconsistency query
and a quote may not be contradicted unquote inquiry.
The third and final test might be called the exclusive statement or complete
integration test.
If I written contract is not deemed to be the exclusive statement of the parties
than extrinsic evidence that is offered as evidence of a supplementary term that
is consistent with the partially integrated terms will be admitted to supplement
the agreement,
but if the written contract is a complete integration,
then the extrinsic evidence of this additional consistent term will not be
admitted.
If the court concludes that such additional consistent terms would quote
necessarily have been included in the writing unquote because the proffered
extrinsic evidence was found to be inconsistent.
The court didn't have to reach this third issue of whether the writing was a
complete and exclusive statement under section two two oh two sub paragraph two.
The court defines this inquiry as whether the consistent term would necessarily
have been included in the writing.
Various courts in describing the scope of the complete integration test have
deployed at least four different adverbs to think about whether the additional
terms would have been included in the original writing they have used
necessarily certainly or narrowly or naturally.
Again,
not a whole lot of guidance.
Think again,
uh,
about Laurel agreeing to paint Hardy's house for $500 but this time,
imagine that hardy wants to present evidence that Laurel also orally agreed to
paint Hardee's tool shed for an extra hundred dollars.
Imagine that the court finds the painting that painting the tool shed for $100.
Is it consistent additional term and that the written house painting contract is
a complete integration?
Maybe because it has a merger clause saying that it is the complete and final
agreement of the parties with the tool shed painting term be the kind that would
necessarily be included in the house painting agreement.
Well,
I'd argue,
no,
it might not necessarily be included.
And so under the Alyeska Standard,
it might be admitted,
but if this were a jurisdiction that used the ordinarily included standard or
reasonable person might come to a different conclusion and find that the tool
shed provision would ordinarily be included in the home painting contract and
therefore refuse to admit the extrinsic evidence as to the tool shed deal.
If you're frustrated by how the UCC treats the parole evidence rule,
you're not alone.
The United States Convention on contracts for the international international
sale of goods known as the CIS G is meant to act as an international version of
the UCC applying by default to the international sale of goods.
Unless the parties include a choice of law provision saying that the contract
will be governed by a,
say the law of New York,
the CIS g has a substantially different take on the parol evidence rule.
Uh,
take a moment to read article eight of the CIS G on this slide.
It basically says that this,
that statements made by parties are to be interpreted according to their intent
and in order to figure out a party's intent,
considerations can be given to relevant circumstances of the negotiation.
So under the CIS g there is no parole evidence rule and extrinsic evidence may
be admitted even with regard to contracts that are written.
Let's work through an example to see how the CIS g would treat an issue
involving parole evidence.
Uh,
an Italian seller of ceramic tiles and an American buyer acting through agents
negotiate an oral agreement of sale that contained agreement on price,
a quality,
quantity,
delivery and payment.
The parties then reduce the negotiated terms,
uh,
to riding on a form prepared by the seller on the front.
Over the signature line.
There was language incorporating terms on the back of the riding into the
contract.
And one of these terms on the back was an additional term about a default and
delay in payment.
The agent signed the contract,
but there was evidence confirmed by affidavits that at the time of signing
neither agent intended that the terms on the back of the writing,
we're part of the contract.
Later there was a dispute over late payment and the seller invoked the delay in
payment term as a defense.
The buyer introduced evidence that neither party intended the back to be part of
the contract,
although language on the friend was not modified to make this intention clear.
The first question is,
is this,
is this evidence admissible under uh,
the CIS G to exclude the default in payment clause?
And the answer is probably yes because of the CIS,
Geez,
very permissive approach toward admitting extrinsic evidence.
Uh,
these affidavits would probably be admitted.
Now the second question,
uh,
suppose the contract was formed between US citizens so that the UCC would apply
with the evidence be admissible under a UCC to two oh two under two,
two oh two.
If a partial integration was inferred,
extrinsic evidence of an oral agreement,
which is inconsistent with the written term,
would not be admitted in general.
However,
section 20 of the restatement would permit the evidence to be admitted.
That section allows cases where both parties have the same intention to control
the enforcement of a contract,
but the parole evidence rule that gets in the way of uh,
can get in the way of the application of this restatement rule.
It's often helpful to create a flowchart to map out how the various aspects,
the various tests of UCC to two oh two interrelate.
Uh,
this slide shows a flow chart created by professor Keith rally.
The Alyeska decision suggests another flow chart that changes the order in which
the questions are asked.
You might do well to write your own.
In summary,
the parole evidence rule.
See Cs two dash two oh two determines when extrinsic evidence can be used to
explain or supplement the terms in a written contract.
The parole evidence rule only applies to integrated writings that is riding a
riding that is final expression of some or all of the terms of the agreement.
The court in this case adopted a three step test to determine if extrinsic
evidence is allowed to supplement.
First,
is the writing partially integrated with regard to the extrinsic evidence at
issue?
If no,
then the extrinsic evidence is allowed even if,
uh,
the evidence is inconsistent or contradictory.
Second,
if the writing is partially integrated,
is the ex external evidence inconsistent or contradictory to the written terms?
If it is inconsistent or contradictory,
then the parole evidence rule applies and the extrinsic evidence cannot be
included.
Third is the complete integration test.
If the contract is a complete integration than extrinsic evidence of even
consistent additional terms will not be admitted.
If the court finds that those additional terms would necessarily have been
included in the writing.
Finally,
uh,
potential fourth desks might ask whether the extrinsic evidence is merely
interpreting existing ambiguous terms.
If it's just interpreting terms,
then it can,
uh,
can be admitted if the integrated but ambiguous term is reasonably susceptible
to the proffered interpretation.
The CIS g avoids this mess of the UCC is parol evidence rule by generally
considering,
uh,
all extrinsic evidence.